welcome to this video playing extra
knocks from Spain and some very
substantial rating difference some
balloon 1900 let's see we have an
English symmetrical I'm taking the
center you can also go with g3 but I
don't mind this this classical approach
the question is should i move the night
maybe i should have considered tonight
b5 earlier to be honest here he may be
can take and play Bishop c6 not the end
of the world but it would help him a bit
yeah but I can do here let's just get on
with normal moves I don't want to
retreat the nite nite be three or
something it doesn't really look look
like a promising news b6 mmm
yeah it's not very active our weight
would we do not whenever the this this
happens Roxy 127 you need to consider 95
yeah come on this will at least a shock
him a bit yeah and it's even good it's
even good ed CD is obviously good using
the C file and though our Knight takes
pawn takes cannot play your mouth must
play Queen d8 or queen somewhere and
then last night e720 75 very important
'if I've attacking the bishop on c6 and
attacking f6 so Bishop f3 that's EF six
winning a piece and after de Fe rock da
da still take on f6 win apiece so I
think I'm winning materially already
change the knee five not don't see a
defense takes defea rook da de take you
seven the Queen saying but that's over
simply
it's always the captcha on f6 happening
with tempo in the Queen it's really
essentially a double attack and after
Bishop f 3 i'm taking end with this
tempo on the Queen I will win the the
bishop get up thus mmm it's the temple
on the Queen
yeah every time I ever check him check
and then taking with two black resigned
two extra bishops yeah well just one
move I mean this position on it it's
nothing special going on he just needs
to avoid Quincy seven Queens his seven
is just like stepping on a mine it's
just uh just instantly explodes and over
really over the most sturdy defense is
taking like that but this is really ugly
this is not winning material but it's
terrible I mean note that this p6 is the
problem also this weakness on c6 yeah
this was check like in the game-winning
material he must have what Quincy 780
across the system just using this is
still a fairly normal position we can
maybe get the Queen here and we have
this Hedgehog type of information I have
played f4 it's not it's a bit more
aggressive than those Hedgehog positions
were whiter plays only have three and
still a very normal position I can i
play probably this this normal
strengthening moves and then see how to
increase the space advantage further
right thanks for watching